felicità vi racconto una storia la
storia è questa
coloro che si occupano come me di
happiness studies di studi sulla
felicità hanno scoperto molto tempo fa
che la percentuale dei nostri
connazionali che si dichiara molto
felice che è stata per tanti decenni una
percentuale fissa intorno al 39 per
cento quasi quattro italiani su dieci
sottoposti alla domanda lei quanto è
felice facendo un bilancio della sua
vita me lo dica per favore con un voto
da 1 minimo a 10 massimo circa quattro
italiani su dieci indicavano voti 8 9 o
10 se aggiungete un altro 20 per cento
che tradizionalmente si dava un voto 7
si smentisce la tesi che l'italia abbia
smesso di essere un paese positivo
perché per tantissimo tempo circa 60 per
cento degli italiani si è definito
discretamente o molto felice e appunto
quasi il 40 per cento molto felice e
questo tasso di felicità dichiarata era
stabile nel tempo non era relativo al
ciclo economico saliva e scendeva al pil
saliva e scendeva il reddito delle
famiglie saliva e scendeva il tenore di
vita
ma gli italiani che si dichiaravano
felici erano sempre la stessa
percentuale è successo poi qualcosa e
questo qualcosa è successo in un momento
specifico nel primo trimestre del 2011
il primo trimestre del 2011
improvvisamente è crollata la diga avete
presente le dighe olandesi dei polver è
venuta giù il bambino prima teneva come
nella favola il dito nel bucchino in
attesa di soccorsi poi il bambino ha
deciso di andarsene e il mare ha invaso
pezzo di olanda e si è perso nel giro di
pochi mesi un quarto degli italiani che
si dichiaravano felici una catastrofe
nel senso stretto in senso tecnico una
discontinuità che per noi i ricercatori
sociali è stata subito apparsa subito
drammatica i motivi
certo la crisi economico sociale
un dato dell'inizio di marzo ci dice che
un campione rappresentativo di italiani
dai 18 anni in su dunque adulti e
anziani si lamenta di come vanno le cose
a lui intervistato a lei e ai suoi cari
e ancora ne misura del 72 per cento
la condizione materiale giudicata
negativa o addirittura drammatica da
quasi tre italiani su quattro ma non è
stato contrariamente a quel che molti
pensano il motivo principale è
principale motivo è stato di carattere
psicologico e culturale
abbiamo perso il nostro ottimismo
tradizionale
l'italia è stata a lungo un paese in cui
l'ottimismo la fiducia nel futuro auto
riferito a breve termine noiosissimo che
vuol dire come crede che andranno le
cose a lei ei suoi cari nel prossimo
anno
ottimismo riferito a sé ai propri cari a
breve termine un anno è sempre stato
molto elevati ho cominciato a fare
ricerche nell 80 e allora scoprì che la
percentuale degli ottimisti era intorno
al 66 per cento due terzi è grosso modo
è rimasta stabile
oggi siamo in una condizione rovesciata
pensate all'inizio di marzo il 62 per
cento dei nostri connazionali adulti
dichiarava nel prossimo anno cioè da lì
alla fine di febbraio da quel momento
alla fine del febbraio del 2015
a me ai miei cari io prevedo io suppongo
io ipotizzo che le cose peggioreranno
il nostro principale problema collettivo
la malattia del futuro il futuro si è
ammalato come ha scritto uno spiritoso
su un muro c'è documentazione
fotografica
il futuro non è più quello di una volta
frase peraltro che ascendenti letterarie
non si sa bene il primo che l'abbia
detto ma fa parte della creatività
collettiva qui ci ha richiamato pasquale
da fiere a il fatto che si reinventa
cose che erano gia state inventate si
chiama saggezza collettiva ebbene il
furto di futuro che hanno subito i
nostri giovani ma anche gli adulti e
molti anziani è stato drammatico e poi
per finire ma poi passo dopo il bastone
alla carota non preoccupatevi non
verranno distribuite pistole per il
suicidio in sala per intenderci però un
po di analisi impietosa può essere utile
guardiamo in faccia la realtà e con le
lenti a brunate il sole come durante
l'eclissi non neghiamo la realtà è
questa malattia del futuro è anche stata
legata a dei vissuti collettivi che mi è
capitata analizzare che sono non capisco
più niente
67 per cento 2 su 3 l'illeggibilità
della realtà ho perso controllo sulla
mia vita non ho più autogoverno
sono stato espropriato tre su quattro è
diminuita l'autostima degli italiani di
un quarto è cresciuta più che
raddoppiando dal 2008 più 111 per cento
più che raddoppiata la dichiarazione di
vivo una vita fortemente stressante vero
che si ha e nel mio mestiere non si
raggiunge mai la verità nel migliore dei
casi ci si avvicina alla verità del
dichiarato forse alla verità del vissuto
non mi sento più protetto le tensioni
l'assistenza le cure drammatico
insomma tutta una serie di cose
chiamiamoli così di fenomeni che hanno
aumentato straordinariamente la
depressione collettiva da un paese
mediterraneo
mediterraneo anche a bolzano è per
intenderci non solo al sud a un paese
che è caduta in una profonda drammatica
inedita depressione collettiva
eppure il titolo del mio specie e felici
malgrado seppur diminuiti di un quarto
coloro che si dichiarano molto felici vi
ricordate voti 8 9 10
in una scala da 1 minimo a 10 massimo
sono comunque tanti quasi il 30 per
cento
se volete una notizia dell'ultima ora da
23 mesi stanno lentamente risalendo il
che è un dato positivo almeno per un
analista sociale lentamente risalendo
allora la domanda che noi ci siamo posti
è ma come hanno fatto
milioni e milioni di italiani a
dichiararsi molto felici malgrado
pagando questa situazione che ho
sommariamente delineato ma che non ne ho
dubbio voi ritrovate nella vostra
esperienza personale o almeno
nell'esperienza di tante delle persone
che incontrate o di cui sentite parlare
e come questa domanda affascina
affascina perché vedete per mestiere
come altri giro il mondo e vedo o faccio
anche ricerche in molti paesi del mondo
tra l'altro le web raisers le ricerche
via internet o aumentato la nostra
capacità di ricercatori di un solo paese
in questo caso l'italia di avere
rapidissimamente a costi molto le
cresciute in formazione pressoché su
tutto il pianeta
cosa vediamo cosa vedo come esperienza
di ricercatore di persona che era
intrattiene rapporti che va all'estero
eccetera che all'estero
la pensano in maniera completamente
diversa ci invidiano
nella convinzione che qui in italia si
vive benissimo che questo sia un paese
di felicità diffusa e non mi riferisco
solo al design al fashion alle
tradizioni enogastronomiche ai piaceri
della vita
qualcosa di più profondo una ricerca
fatta dall'eurobarometro un'istituzione
pressoché ufficiale dell'unione europea
mostra che l'italia è sempre stata e
continua ad essere ai primissimi posti
qualche anno al primo posto in una
curiosa classifica quella delle risposte
alla domanda ma lei se non fosse nato in
polonia austria germania uk ecc dove
vorrebbe essere nato l'italia italia
disprezzata è per la nostra illegalità
la nostra confusione il nostro barocco
incomprensibile sistema politico
la nostra inaffidabilità
se un impegno imprese italiane
esportatrici ce ne sono tante anche qui
in provincia di bergamo consegna
puntualmente dicono sono italiani ma
hanno consegnato puntualmente ma ma
hanno consegnato malgrado alcune livelli
avrei una parolaccia sulla bocca ma lo
dico in inglese per un femminismo di
calo della reputazione o di bassa
reputazione noi siamo ritenuti un paese
di gente che si sa godere la vita che sa
essere felice d'altra parte c'è un'altra
ricerca sempre di euro bar di qualche
tempo fa in cui è stato chiesto a gente
dai 40 anni ai 60 anni in tutta europa
compresa di nuovi paesi e l'onore
europea ma lei dove le piacerebbe andare
nel suo re thai arment diciamolo andare
in pensione anche se non tutta italia
primo posto
una volta c'era il chiantishire adesso
c'è il salento le città d'arte
la domanda che mi faccio è che occuperà
la seconda parte un intervento è ma
perché gli altri reputano che esista lo
dico in inglese perché a livello
internazionale dello si dice in questa
specie di esperanto obbligatorio che
l'inglese riconoscono a noi una sorta di
ancient art owen levin arte antica
millenaria di vivere bene perché ci
viene riconosciuto un italian way to
happiness una via italiana alla felicità
e di che cosa è fatta allora non vi dico
le mie opinioni
vi dico cosa dicono gli italiani che
seppur diminuiti 29 per cento adesso 30
da qualche tempo dicono di essere molto
felice
quali sono le dieci cose ambiti di
esperienza che fanno parte di questa
specie di ricetta italiana della
felicità
una sorta di gastronomia dello spirito
per così dire quali sono gli ingredienti
primo dopo tanti e giusti discorsi sulla
tecnologia il più vicino più vicino vuol
dire certo migliaia di amici o decine di
migliaia di mitch su facebook
certo il mondo globalizzato è reso
immediatamente disponibile
e oggi anche portabile con gli
smartphones con i tablet
non c'è più bisogno del tavolo per il
computer quindi un universo che si è
allargato e però la felicità è legata di
più che in passato al vicino pochi
familiari in quanto cari non in quanto
familiari necessariamente non tutti i
familiari sono cari pochi amici veri la
propria comunità locale o professionale
il rione l'ospedale la scuola per chi ci
lavora più vicino si allargano gli
orizzonti ma la felicità è legata a una
sorta di rimpicciolimento del perimetro
e questo è legato molto a quella
sensazione di perdita di controllo per
cui viceversa se io controllo un
territorio piccolo lo domino meglio o
meno ansia
il secondo elemento tipicamente italiano
all'estero ne sono tutti convinti e la
relazionalità una felicità che non è
legata all
ma è legata a noi è legata agli rapporti
che ciascuno di noi se ne è capace
instaura con gli altri
una relazionalità estroversa all'estero
aggiungerebbero gesticolante è la cosa
che dicono subito degli italiani
due cose dicono che ho fatto ricerche
internazionali gli italiani gesticolano
e dieci persone se sei incerto ad un
incrocio corrono e ti vogliono spiegare
senza sapere l'inglese nessun'altra
lingua qual è la strada
purtroppo i tedeschi aggiungono che le
10 indicazioni sono contraddittorie tra
di loro ma coi tedeschi
i tedeschi hanno nei nostri confronti
lo stesso rapporto che i politici a
italiani hanno nei confronti della
signora merkel a cui pure tutti vanno a
pacche sulle spalle non basta la
relazione ma anche il calore il calore
il calore qualcuno dirà il sesso sì gli
italiani sostengono nella crisi di avere
fatto più all'amore
forse anche perché attività gratuite e
il genere voglio dire non mi occupo di
marketing della prostituzione quindi
piacevole gratuita easy disposable è
portabile anch'essa ma a parte il sesso
farlo
a parte il sesso parlo di amore parlo
specialmente di emozioni lo dico col
titolo di una canzone vecchia della
nostra tradizione che è molto
identificata con gli italiani lo
stereotipo dell'italiano all'estero ma è
anche parte importante della nostra way
to happiness della nostra arte antica
anema e core anema e core
quindi attenzione abbiamo sentito cose
meravigliose e stato colpito dalla
relazione dell'astrofisico adesso
dell'oncologo eccetera ovviamente la
razionalità e con essa la tecnologia
nel peso hanno avuto e hanno avranno un
peso essenziale per lo sviluppo non si
vive di solo poesia ma si vive anche di
poesia anema e core
poi nella relazionalità un punto chiave
quello che personalmente poi a noi piace
di più che il prefisso po o quello della
fare le cose insieme un tema che avete
visto è già stato evocato più vuoti
cooperare condividere colloquiare e così
via
vedete nelle momenti di crisi per un
motivo in più ed è che siccome nei
momenti di crisi l'erta della vita
diventa più scoscesa la vita è più
faticosa beh come voi sapete se siete
stati montane anche solo a camminare non
dico a scalare si scala meglio in gruppo
e si scala meglio legati con una corda
si perde di velocità perché si va alla
velocità del membro più napoli piena
consapevolezza perché essendo grasso fin
da piccolo sono sempre stato l'ultimo no
però però
però restare in cordata bollire salire
con più sicurezza e qualche volta con
più chiacchiere magari canti anche se ti
manca il fiato in montagna e non parlo
del cioccolato novi in cui la relazione
a due peraltro allora come voi sapete
comunque o con una cosa che ri
sorprenderà ragazze e ragazzi i valori
noi abbiamo una percezione di barbari
d'azione della nostra vita collettiva di
materialismo di consumismo tutti questi
ismi invece non è così è
guardate che e le ricerche che noi
conduciamo mostrano che nel fuoco della
crisi la gente ha dato più importante
agli ideali agli aspetti immateriali
certo anche perché non si pagano cioè
sono fuori dal circuito monetario del
circuito economico commerciale ma la
gente si rende conto che per essere
felici conviene conviene proprio è utile
avere dei valori dei valori che vanno al
di là dell'esperienza quotidiana che per
definizione sono condivisi con altri non
esistono valori individuali per un
sociologo per un antropologo e che fanno
una cosa importante ci fanno da bussola
e cioè ci aiutano a fare una delle cose
che dà più felicità che è trovare un
senso nella vita e senza una parola
bellissima vuol dire tante cose vuol
dire anche molto mi fa senso ma
specialmente vuol dire direzione e
significato sono due cose che noi umani
cerchiamo e questa è la vera differenza
rispetto agli animali oltre a dire bugie
complesse ea saper pensare alla nostra
morte i veri elementi di distinzione
rispetto anche agli animali più evoluti
e noi cerchiamo a volte troviamo e
quando troviamo siamo felici un senso
badate una direzione verso cui muoversi
e che in genere è una meta che non
raggiungeremo
e un impegno che si attiva che non è
detto porti a risultati ma comunque
dal viaggio conta il biancio muoversi da
ha anche senza mai a raggiungere e
questo aiuta moltissimo
poi certo il modello italiano comprende
quello che in inglese si chiama bliss
che forse tradotto vorrei dire
beatitudine la che noi di solito negli
studi sulla felicità
indichiamo come la capacità che noi
italiani abbiamo fortemente quando manca
la grande felicità per esempio perché
c'è stato un lutto terribile per si è
perso un amore una persona cara il
lavoro la sicurezza eccetera la capacità
che noi abbiamo di ricercare le gocce di
felicità non una condizione
integralmente felice ma degli attimi di
felicità
la musica che esce da una finestra
aperta e che ci emozionano ci ricorda
qualcosa
il sorriso di un bambino la bellezza di
un monumento il calore della preghiera
ognuno sceglie e testimonia quello che
vuole
siamo verso la fine un altro punto è
importante la cultura della abbastanza
mirare a molto ma accontetarsi di
abbastanza un punto chiave un punto
chiave perché non è vero per esempio
diventando sempre più ricchi si diventa
più felice le ricerche in tutto il mondo
mostrano che la povertà è un ottimo modo
per essere infelici aiuta molto essere
infelici la grande ricchezza no basta
arrivare ad un certo livello e sapere
accontentarsi e poi è stato detto il
bello la bellezza felicità è stato in
parte detto il dono aiutare gli altri
aiuta chi aiuta donare aiuta al donante
non meno perdonato e poi per finire
sognare sognare e che vuol dire con
curiosità anche illudersi allora
conclude raccontando il concetto di
sogno in una storiellina che quella di
un topolino
intendo proprio un bambino topolino
che vede in cielo un pipistrello animale
orrendo senza offesa e specialmente
pericoloso perché si nutre di topi
specialmente i topolini
eppure malgrado questo questo vuol dire
sognare il topolino
parlando con sua mamma dice è la fine
dell'italian way to happiness mamma
guarda un angelo
grazie
debole giano quello che metto lì spero
che apprezzerete che è un messaggio
situazionali non avevo scritto un altro
o finto ringrazio l'organizzazione di
avere perso il primo perché ne ho fatto
un altro alla luce di quello che ho
sentito è il mio corso recita dal
criscito triste
vi ricordate quello di fabio cleto
triste alla gallina felice voi direte
perché la gallina ragazze e ragazzi poco
poco colloquiare condividere costruire
operare